your husband has three nominations - now
come on now you know he was also a grip
on a star is born
so yeah working like a Jamaican like a
13 job my mum you got one job how do you
choose where you sit well so the
individual nomination is for Randall for
this is us so I'll be with mighty IU
family because I'm with them seven
months out of the year
but I go see my brothers and sisters
over in Wakanda uh-huh I'll hop back and
forth the load back I'm not gonna hear
Black Panther I'm gonna hear what
conduct take a xanax I didn't wait how
did he do taking care of the babies when
mama was off doing her thing on her big
show okay I wouldn't you like this I got
a tweet from a friend of mine who was
like girl I saw your man and your two
child children and let me tell you
everybody had clothes on and nobody with
a she is this series it's great you know
we're done your apps I've you know bid
adieu to New York it was so good being
back in New York as such a may I lived
in Brooklyn it was like a dream come
true you know and came out for Christmas
it was I mean it was as wonderful as it
could have been but I just hope that we
get to see it and everybody likes it
let me ask you this Miranda wins the
election yeah did you didn't really
think he was gonna win the election that
surprised you right I think well I know
what the storyline was from the
beginning of the season so I knew he was
gonna win but I also knew that it was
going to cause a little bit of
disruption in his marriage as well I
love when actors collide on the red
carpet I gotta I gotta ask you something
because I understand you want him on
marvelous mrs. Mayes yes I do
I would give anything I do right here
right now for this tell me this why is
it sterling Kate Brown that you say oh
no no no we need him because sterling is
incredible and can literally do no wrong
every time I see you drilling in
something else
I've loved our mutual love I'm just I
would I would follow sterling to the end
of the earth it goes both ways it's just
the show is done it's such an incredibly
high level it's so funny it's so full of
heart it's so specific like I love the
specificity of the world and it's like I
would love to step in that the Paula
Dino's are so clear and what they're
doing you know is like that's the kind
of people that you want to work with all
you guys are in the house where you're
fixing the house or a summer
it's like theater that we get to be a
part of that's so beautiful here but I
believe I'd get back to what you were
doing
[Music]